the country of russia has decided that
they are not going to be abrasive
towards bitcoin and cryptocurrencies the
news broke late last night in the
russian national paper that the russian
government and the central bank has
reached an agreement they are going to
treat bitcoin and cryptocurrencies just
like regular currencies this is a huge
deal because previously the central bank
the bank of russia wanted to ban bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies they did not want
to actually allow their citizens to
participate many people don't know this
but the country of russia is one of the
largest countries for crypto adoption
they're the third largest bitcoin miner
according to hash rate in the entire
world there's over 12 million russian
citizens that hold cryptocurrencies and
it's estimated that about 26 billion
dollars worth of crypto is held by those
12 million people russian citizens have
shown that they want to hold bitcoin in
cryptocurrencies and now the russian
government is saying you know what we're
going to let you do it they issued a
statement and in that what they have
said is that they are going to treat
bitcoin cryptocurrencies like regular
currencies they're also going to license
various crypto exchanges if you're not
licensed you're in trouble they're going
to provide all sorts of frameworks
around taxation and regulatory
compliance and then lastly is they're
also going to require people to submit
information to a nation-state-run
surveillance system that knows who has
what assets and when they're transacting
with who
ultimately to see a superpower like
russia get into the game here is
important because it forces the hands of
other countries around the world bitcoin
is an open decentralized payment system
it doesn't care if you or i participate
it doesn't care what nation states are
participating it simply produces block
after block after block of transactions
russia is already under immense pressure
from the united states around financial
sanctions about the potential invasion
of ukraine they've been budding up with
china a friendly of the united states
they've been talking about bilateral
trade and settling in a currency other
than the u.s dollar and so naturally
russia is likely to be interested in
that decentralized open payment system
that no one controls and no one can
censor bitcoin is censorship resistant
money sanctions are censorship and if
you're facing that censorship you
probably become interested in something
like this and just so to see the country
of russia going ahead and saying we want
to participate that is a very big deal
no one on the national stage or on the
international stage can ignore it now
and then ultimately we have this quote
here from the russian official and what
they say in this quote is that the
implementation of the concept will
ensure the creation of the necessary
regulatory framework it will bring the
digital currency industry out of the
shadows and create the possibility of
legal business activities
russia's going all in on bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies vladimir putin
obviously sees the value to his citizens
and to his country now it's time for the
united states to act are we going to sit
by and let other superpowers become the
leader on the global stage or will the
united states have the courage and the
conviction to be the leader we must act
now the stakes are too high america must
embrace bitcoin russia's gonna do it
what are we gonna do